rick spielman vikings gm close to an
extension that means
kirk cousins mike zimmer rick spielman
all get their rewards
from last year's birth in the nfl's
final eight the one guy still waiting is
running back dalvin cook chris but the
other three guys got their extensions
it'll be interesting to see if cook gets
his yeah well it will be i i think it's
gonna be dicey uh maybe they make it a
little sweetener or something like that
but it's good to see with brook spielman
i mean it is i mean he's done a
phenomenal job ever since he's been
working in that organization you know
there hasn't been too many years you can
look at the players on that team or that
roster and you go
man
they they got some major holes i mean
it's really has not existed and i know
he's only been the gm since when was it
like 2012 or 13. i can't but before that
he was i know the vice president of pro
personnel you know so when i just look
at those things and his long haul there
in minnesota i go damn he knows what pro
personnel looks like and he certainly
has drafted well and they've done a good
job in free agency and you know for the
most part i know they're not winning
super bowls like a vikings fan would
want but you guys are relevant most
years and in the payoff conversation
most years and i i do think that counts
for something certainly
rick spielman joined the vikings in 2006
as the vp of player personnel they had
that strange situation they created what
they called the triangle of authority
between the coach
the vp of player personnel who was fran
foley at the time and their contracts
guy rob brzezinski
uh and then fran foley had some resume
issue and he was gone barely after he
got there that's when spielman showed up
and he became the gm as you said 2012. i
mean he's lasted a long time with the
vikings and you know they they have been
we talked about this with mike zimmer's
contract yeah they
they contend right right they're kind of
on the fringes they've had two years
since spielman's been there where they
played in the nfc championship game 2009
and 2017
but they've yet to be dominant
and it's hard to tell whether or not
they're they're putting the wheels in
motion for a team that could be dominant
but uh they they've constantly been a
team that is relevant in december yeah
you know that's the key you can say we
want to win the super bowl the key is
to be relevant past thanksgiving to have
teams care about you
in the month of december
as the playoffs are approaching even if
you don't make it every year you're
still in the conversation and it seems
like every year except for 2011
every year they've been in the
conversation yeah there's something to
be said about that you know
there is there's a lot of teams that
haven't been crap the last eight nine
years in the nfl you know like like i
you know i echoed those same things mike
i mean you know it's been good defensive
football players there you know had
adrian peterson teddy bridgewater made
an appropriate move to get kirk cousins
because he felt like there was a
quarterback issue there
he's drafted well you know they've tried
their best to keep homegrown talent yeah
you're right they're just missing that
piece or two that's gotten them over the
edge but you know like you said i just i
can't really remember a year in december
or anything like that where i went
vikings are in the playoff combo or
vikings are going to be in the playoffs
can they make a real serious run yeah
most years i've said no i don't think
they can make a serious run but they're
a playoff team and that's kind of how i
look at them right now i guess i i don't
look at you guys as a super bowl
contender
uh i think you're kind of in a semi
rebuild on the run type thing where i go
playoffs yes deep in the playoffs i
don't know if i can get my head around
that there in minnesota quite yet right
now what's this you guys crap you guys
guys your team right your team that's
why you asked for the purple backgrounds
right here at nbc you were like i'm a
vikings fan i want a little purple mixed
in
here here's the thing
in an alternate universe the vikings
lost to the saints in the wild card
round last year i wonder if those
extensions are all handed out if the
vikings had lost that game to the saints
that is it very interesting and just how
much that game
you know i just remember going into the
49ers game i couldn't get over how many
people then swayed their oh i think the
vikings are going to beat san francisco
that weekend too i was shocked at the
amount of people that kind of jumped on
the bandwagon since they beat the saints
but yeah i certainly think that made the
extension conversation a little easier
in the fact that they won another
playoff game this past year
and on that point dalvin cook had a
pretty big role in that playoff game he
had 94 yards rushing against the saints
and two touchdowns and 36 receiving
that's 130 from scrimmage so i think the
fact that cousins and zimmer and
spielman have all gotten theirs is only
going to make cook more intent and i've
heard nothing to substantiate this
but
it won't shock me if he opts out
it won't if they're not going to give
him his contract now look it doesn't
really help him all it does is press
pause until next year when he'd be
getting 1.3 million same salary he'd get
this year but the vikings would have to
go forward without him this year period
you guys are well i don't mean to keep
saying you guys but i'm going to keep
saying it i mean so i'm just looking
salary cap wise right now i know you
were up against it 25th in football as a
spot track right now
you know just with the dalvin cook
situation i'm with you i hear nothing to
think that he's going to get a long-term
extension but you know i would hope
at the very least
you know maybe they can find a way to do
like what the 49ers did with raheem
mostert something you know just a little
sweetener i don't know what those terms
were but a little sweetener some very
maybe very attainable
you know uh goals as far as oh you get
800 yards rushing you get 500 000 you
know you get a thousand yards russian
you get a million or a million five you
know that would be the kind of thing i
would look at look to do for a guy like
dalvin cook if i was running the vikings
the fact that we still don't know what
the most terms are underscores the fact
that
it's probably not a real good deal for
the player but we'll see what happens i
mean that's the thing to watch as the
day unfolds
will they get the deal done between the
league and the union and when will the
opt-out deadline be because the teams
don't like the fact that some agents are
using that opt-out deadline yeah that
possibility to walk away for the season
as leverage to get these deals and i
think dalvin cook if if we're going to
make a list of guys who should be
considering it dalvin cook should be at
the top of the list at 1.3 million for
this year
hey maybe maybe i do opt out if you're
not going to give me the contract that
i've earned capped by what i did to help
the team win the playoff game in new
orleans against the saints it's uh it's
you know every day it's amazing how much
is going on chris and we're going to
keep everybody on top of all the ins and
outs
at profotballtalk.com
but uh you know even though it's not a
real training camp it feels like it's
busier than ever with all the different
stuff that's going on as we try to
figure out what's going to happen yeah
no i know i mean i think that's going to
dominate our conversation we don't have
preseason games to talk about i'm not
going to be able to break down
pre-season film and tell you you know
what rookie looks good or anything like
that so
uh i think it's going to be all this
just you know where's it go this team's
doing that the nfl is juggling this and
here's the new protocol for testing
whatever it may be i think that's the
time we're in right now we'll be talking
about this stuff a lot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports